what's going on everybody welcome and
thank you for 550 thousand subscribers I
really can't thank you all enough I get
to be a youtuber talking about my
favorite thing in the world Marvel and
it's all thanks to you all and your
support that you give me and I will be
eternally grateful for it and that's why
I enjoy doing these giveaways now this
giveaway took a long time because it
took a pretty long time to get to five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
from five hundred thousand so instead
what we're going to do now is I'm going
to do weekly giveaway is going to be
given away Funko pops going to be giving
away gift cards and when the movies
eventually start coming out
IMAX gift cards as well and these
giveaways will be once a week that way
more people have an opportunity to win
and we'll start those soon I'm also
going to be doing pretty big giveaways
on Instagram and Twitter so don't forget
to follow me on there as well
but let's get into this giveaway as
always the winner is chosen at complete
random the winner has to be subscribed
and has to comment on a video I use a
program that randomly chooses a winner
it is 100% random so we've chosen a
random video and a random winner is
Leonardo Santos Congrats you get to
choose between an xbox one or a ps4 your
choice email me in the email that's in
the about Me section on my channel and
we'll get you your prize but the rest of
you thank you so much we're going to
continue to do giveaways like I said
weekly giveaways and then random big
giveaways like this as well and then on
Twitter and Instagram to again thank you
all so much I truly appreciate all the
love and support that you give me and I
hope to continue to bust out videos that
you enjoy and love thank you so much and
of course as always thank you so much
for watching
wolf wolf